now South Africa says it's taking firm
action to restore law and order after a
wave of anti-immigrant violence in which
at least seven people have been killed
more than 300 people have been arrested
across the country in connection with
the tax on foreign nationals the unrest
began in the port city of Durban two
weeks ago and spread to Johannesburg
Africa's economic hub well we spoke to
the journalists of Romani MKZ who's in
Devon we're in the third week of the
xenophobic violence that's been plaguing
South Africa and in kwazulu-natal where
the xenophobic attacks originated we've
had a quiet weekend on Saturday
President Jacob Zuma cancelled his trip
the reserved he was meant to go to
Indonesia on a state visit and to deal
with matters at home and he went to the
chest with refugee camp the camp has
mostly milan's zimbabweans and some
members of the Burundian community and
he spoke with him to actually try and
reassure them that the South African
government is doing all it can to
protect them unfortunately most of the
foreign nationals who are housed in that
camp didn't receive the president's
message too well as saying president you
coming here too late they had made up
their minds that they wanted to go home
and there was nothing that the president
could do to actually try and dissuade
them obviously these people have been
subjected to savage attacks by South
Africans we've been chasing them out of
their houses looting their shops and
basically telling them to go back home
go back where they are to where they
come from at the refugee camps buses
have started coming in from as far
afield as Malawi Mozambique and Zimbabwe
and we getting ambassadors from these
countries coming in and to actually
document these migrants in order to
actually assist in taking them back home
there's a variety of reasons why these
in a phobic attacks are happening um you
know South Africa is a multicultural
country but there's a tendency from
South African locals in particular to
mistrust foreigners from Africa and
there's also a competition for resources
South Africa may seem like it's a very
rich country particularly for Africans
but there's still a lot of poverty in
vulture there's a myriad of issues that
are affecting local South Africans and
they feel that the foreigners are taking
away from them
resources their jobs so it all comes
together and and creates this negative
foreigner sentiments in the country and
also we've had irresponsible comments
from from from leaders who zulu king as
good girls really teeny made a speech
about three weeks ago calling for
foreign nationals in posted in it all to
pack their bags and leave obviously
within this mixture of a fancy foreigner
sentiment that's pervasive in South
Africa it may have exacerbated a
situation and after the King had made
that statement we saw that the beginning
of this in a phobic attacks happening
internships throughout was in Natal it
has started to quieten down particularly
here in kwazulu-natal where we haven't
had an attack since Wednesday but in
houghton johannesburg in particular
there have been a continuation of
attacks and so the situation still
remains a very volatile over there as we
know this situation it fluctuates some
nights it might be quiet and it might
pick up again but there's a large
government intervention in order to
actually prevent further attacks